gorgeous grilled lamb copters with my
incredible twist on a middle-eastern
classic hummus first job glorious
beetroot hummus I'm going to blend and
puree the cooked chickpea and the
beetroot now the B room gives that
particularly delicious flavor to hummus
be ruse in with the chickpea a nice
seasoning of salt and pepper a
tablespoon of olive oil a tablespoon of
tahini this is roasted sesame seeds
pounded and mixed with oil now crushed
garlic and toasted cumin seeds grind
then pop into a blender
[Applause]
[Music]
I love that nice dark rich color and you
finish it with a nice lemon slice it in
half take Heather seeds and squeeze the
fresh lemon juice at the ends just
weights up the acidity in the B roof but
really cuts the richness of the chickpea
and the lemon juice is pivotal it really
brings the beetroot and the chickpeas
together chickpeas are packed with
protein very dense and it needs that
kind of acidity
one more little blend lovely
nice taste delicious homemade beer dude
hummus so tasty and it really is that
easy to make to finish some toasted
cumin seeds and sumac
now this delicious it's a sort of Middle
Eastern spice and then some sesame seeds
finish that off with marjoram hummus
done now for my copters pan on onion
nice and finely diced garlic three nice
close
squeeze the garlic over the onions
onions garlic in you get a really nice
color on them
after that a nice teaspoon of chili
flakes now into a pestle and mortar with
a teaspoon of toasted cumin just salt in
there helps to kind it down that lovely
smell aromatic exciting spicy intriguing
once ground to a fine powder sprinkle
your spices into the onion and garlic to
create a wonderful aromatic paste now
for the lamb mince lightly seasoned it
and then add all that wonderful flavor
next for some freshness parsley and mint
roughly chopped and a glug of olive oil
hands in there you give that a really
good mix traditionally you can see
afters on little sticks barbecue skewers
and depending where you are
they have different sort of variations
and shapes of sizes I much prefer the
nice little sort of almost like little
mini burgers like little mini sliders
but these can be griddled these can be
fried in a pan or even cooked on the
barbecue start by rolling the mix into a
golf ball size and then flatten out
always like the oil your plate that way
when you set them in the fridge they
don't need to be all again that you can
strain to the bankers we got oil
underneath and all on top
keep your hands lightly oiled and it
helps to stop the lamb I'm sticking to
your fingers then pop them into the
fridge to set and firm up before cooking
now cook the copper in a frying pan on
the barbecue or an amazing little
griddle pan gets the plaque really nice
and hot whilst that heat
I'm making a yogurt dip I love a nice
sort of fresh minted yogurt put fresh
mint leaves salt and a pinch of toasted
cumin and black pepper into a pestle and
mortar to grind as you start to sort of
blend the mint almost turns into a nice
fresh mint puree we smell out of that is
incredible add yogurt and I like Greek
best and a squeeze of lemon
look at that now beautiful now the
copter so they go on
[Music]
one of the biggest problems on cooking
chakra is that they move them too early
and they start to break up but let them
grill and by grilling them they'll
naturally lift off the bar once they're
charcoal and so literally two to five
minutes each side now beautiful smell is
incredible once browned on both sides
they're ready to serve
[Music]
delicious I absolutely love lunches like
this because it's sort of bold food
that's packed full of freshness and
great flavors these quick and easy minty
lamb kofta so with be true hummus are
perfect for a relaxed meal your family
and friends will all want to talk into